USA USA
USA only you can stop this triumphal
mosque on the cherished site of
conquered land only you you are not your
sentiments are not being reflected in
our
politicians but listen it's a government
by the people and for the people is it
not
I I I bless you for making this
pilgrimage to pay our respects to our
cherished loved ones whose lives were
extinguished torn from the bosom of
their families their communities our
country we are standing in the shadow of
the world's largest Multicultural
Center yes that was a Multicultural
Center of Peace tolerance and okay and
and and love uh yes our keynote speak
today har builders personifies get cheer
I want a cheer
woohoo that's right he came all the way
from
Holland oh my
god listen I'm gonna I'm G to cut my
introduction but this man is my hero
fielders thank you
thank you
Pamela ladies and gentlemen let me start
by saying no mask
[Applause]
here for 10 seconds
what we hear here in New York are the
sounds of life of the greatest city on
earth no place in the world no place in
human history is as vibrant and dynamic
as New York City you hear the
C you hear the cars you hear the people
you hear them rushing to their various
destinations you hear the sounds of
business and pleasure you hear the
cheers you hear the cries the buzzing
sounds of human activity and that is how
it should be always but if you close
your eyes and please close your eyes
it's a beautiful day but close your eyes
I have been told that this day nine
years ago was just
the same as today A beautiful day and
remember or try to remember try to
imagine the sounds that were heard here
exactly on this spot under the same Blue
Sky exactly 9 years
ago those were the sounds of shock the
sounds of Destruction the sounds of
panic the sounds of pain the sounds of
Terror the sounds of war and did New
York deserve this did America deserve
this no did the West deserve it of
course we did not deserve this and we
don't deserve a mosque on Ground Zero
[Applause]
either what my friends would you say to
people and unfortunately those people
exist people that argue that New York
that America that the West had itself to
blame for those terrible
sounds there are people unfortunately in
this city who argue this and they are
angry because we are gathered here today
to
commemorate to make a stand and to we
have to and this is what we have to do
to draw the
line my friends I have come from the
other side of the Atlantic to share your
grief for those who died here 9 years
ago I have not forgotten how I felt that
day the scenes are imprinted on my soul
as they are on yours but our hearts
Hearts were not broken in the same way
as the hearts of the relatives and
Friends of those who lost their lives
here and many relatives of the victims
are here in our midst today and I wish
nine years later but still I wish to
take this opportunity to express my
deepest and most heartfelt condolences
to them and to all the people of New
York and this beautiful country
[Music]
America humbly I stand here before you
as a Dutchman and as a European I too
however cannot forget how can anyone
forget and let me remind you of the
words from Daryl Worley's 911 song
that's I hope and presume most of you
know devil rle sang have you forgotten
how it felt that day to see your
Homeland Under Fire and our people Blown
Away have you forgotten when those
Towers fell we had neighbors still
inside going through a living hell and
wh's response ladies and gentlemen
Worley's response is our response no we
will never
forget we
are we are here today because we have
not forgotten all the loved ones that
were lost and those left to carry on and
neither has the world when the forces of
jihad attacked New York they attacked
the world
and amongst
those lost were people from 55 Nations
people of every religion of every
persuasion no place on Earth on Earth
was more multiethnic and M lingual than
New York's Prouds towers and this ladies
and gentlemen this is exactly the reason
that they were targeted they constituted
an insult to those who hold that there
can be no peaceful cooperation among
people and Nation without submission to
Sharia to
[Applause]
those indeed to those who wish to impose
the legal system of the Islamic ideology
to the rest of
us
but as we all know as we all know
America New York and Sharia are
incompatible New
York New York stands for freedom for
openness and for tolerance indeed New
York is rooted in Dutch tolerance New
York is tolerant not intolerant suppose
New York were intolerant
suppose it would only allow people of
one persuasion within its walls then it
would not be New York but it would be
like
[Applause]
Mecca
Mecca a City without Freedom whatever
your religion your persuasion or your
gender is in New York you will find a
home but in
if your religion is not Islam you are
not even welcome to enter the
city ladies and gentlemen Imam FAL Abdul
Ru who by the way is not a moderate this
Imam claims the right to build the
mosque a house of sharia here on this
Hallowed
Ground but friends
my friends but we have not
forgotten that is why we are here today
to draw the line here today on this
sacret
spot we are
here we are here today in the spirit of
America's founding fathers we we are
here today in the spirit of Freedom we
are here today in the spirit of
President Abraham Lincoln who freed the
slams and president lincol he said and
let me
quote those who deny freedom to others
deserve it not for
themselves and
these these important words are key to
our
survival the tolerance that is crucial
to our
freedom requires a line of defense and
Mayor Bloomberg uses tolerance as an
argument to allow Imam rou and his
sponsors to build a so-called Cordoba
musk but
mayor but Mayor Bloomberg your mayor he
forgets however that openness can never
be open-ended a tolerant Society is not
a suicidal
Society a tolerant Society like your
City New York must defend itself against
the powers of Darkness the forces of
hatred the blight of ignorance it cannot
it cannot tolerate
the intolerant and survive and this
means that we must never give a free
hand to those who want to subjugate
us ladies and
gentlemen an overwhelming majority of
Americans is opposed to building this
musque but so is an overwhelming
majority of people everywhere in the
non-islamic
world because we realize we do realize
what is at stake here we know what this
so-called Cobar mosque really
means Imam Ru maintains that American
secular law and Sharia law are based on
the same
principles Imam rou refuses to condemn
terrorist because he says that terrorism
I quote is a very complex question he
says and I quote again Imam Ru that
America is an accessory to the crime
that happened on
911 in
fact Imam Ru said in the most direct
sense I quote him again Osama Bin Laden
is made in the USA
and terrorism will only end if the West
acknowledges the harm it has done to
Muslims ladies and gentlemen this crazy
and idiotic remarks of this extreme Imam
proves that this man should never play
the game he has in mind here in
[Applause]
Manhattan
is is blame the West blame America
message is an insult Americans and by
extension all of us whose civilization
was also attacked on 911 2001 are not to
blame for what happened here 9 years ago
and Osama B Laden is not made in the U
made in the USA and the West has never
harmed Islam before Islam has harmed us
all the time centuries over and over
again
again and that should
stop most Americans do not want this
so-called cam musque to be built here
because they understand that it's not
only a provocation but it's also a
humiliation they understand the trium
triumphant Narrative of a mosque called
named after the great M of Coda which
was constructed where Christian
Cathedral stood before that land was
conquered by Islam and an overwhelming
majority of Americans is opposed to
building an Islamic mosque close to
Ground Zero there is no lack of mosques
in New York the contrary dozens of
buildings where Muslims can pray it's
not about a lack of space for prayer
it's about the symbolic meaning and we
should not allow that to happen
[Applause]
here
wait
indeed no Musk
here ladies and gentlemen we who have
come to speak here today object to this
mus project because its promoter and his
wealthy sponsors have never never ever
suggested building a center to promote
tolerance and Interfaith understanding
where it's really needed in Saudi Arabia
in
Mecca talking about reciprocity in Saudi
Arabia in Mecca it's impossible to enter
let alone build churches synagogues
temples or whatsoever so why should we
do
that ladies and gentlemen ordinary
Americans object to the musk project
because currently no fewer than 10 major
multi-million dollar musk projects are
being planned in the United States as
well as dozens in Europe while not a
single church is allowed in Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia while Jews are not even
allowed to move their myth their lips on
prayer on the Temple mount in Jerusalem
while while the oldest while the oldest
Christians in the world the cops are not
free to renovate their churches let
alone to build one in
Egypt my friends that exactly that
is why we are here today what happens in
New York must be seen in the perspective
of the
world the
events the events nine years ago made an
enormous impact everywhere and most
people most people of course shared your
pain but unfortunately some did not nine
years ago when the news of the terrible
atrocity in New York reached Europe some
Muslim youth danced in the
streets in a pole in a pole in my own
country 2third of the Muslim immigrants
in the Netherlands expressed partial of
full understanding for the
911 terrorist so if a musk would be be
built here on Ground Zero such people
would feel triumphant and we should
never ever give them that feeling
[Applause]
ladies and
gentlemen we as we are standing here
today we will never betray those who
died on
9/11 for their sakes we cannot ever
tolerate a mosque on Ground
Zero for their sakes for their sakes we
should say loud and clear no m
here mask
here indeed no mask
here
we for their sakes for their sakes we
must draw the line so that New York
rooted in Dutch tolerance will never
become from New
Mecca but let us also use
today to express our gratitude for the
heroes of 9/11 those who went down in
that Pennsylvania field those who were
standing Freedom's watch at the Pentagon
and those who were here in New York 9
years ago to risk and lose the lives for
the victims they deserve our
[Applause]
Applause my
friends in honor of these victims these
Heroes and their families I believe that
the words of Ronald Reagan spoken in
Normandy on the 4th anniversary of dday
resonate resonate with new purpose on
this hallowed spot President Reagan said
and I quote we will always remember we
will always be proud We will always be
prepared so we may always be
[Applause]
free and
we as we are standing here we too will
always remember the victims of 9/11 and
the loved ones who were left behind we
too will always be proud of the heroes
we will always defend Liberty democracy
and human dignity and that's why I end
with my last sentence in the name of
Freedom no mque here thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]